Jeudi 3 août il est 23 heures à Mâcon
Sandra 37 ans rentre au camping où elle
réside
elle traverse un passage piéton non loin
de la boîte de nuit le 400 soudain une
voiture démarre en trombes
[Musique]
elle lui roule dessus et prend la fuite
sandra est gravement blessé
au départ un simple fait divers mais
quelques jours plus tard une information
bouleverse le scénario le 9 août
j'apprends que la personne mise en cause
dans le fait divers du 3 août à Mâcon et
Marouane béréni c'est quelques jours
après le 11 août est porté à notre
connaissance la voiture retrouvée par
les gendarmes le lendemain de faits
divers la voiture se trouve au bord de
la route dans le Rhône à Fleury qui se
gérait de sa voiture en tout cas de
celles qui l'utilisent lorsqu'il habite
en Saône-et-Loire qui n'est pas en
tournage Marouane béréni alias Maître
Abdel Fedala
avocat dans la série Plus Belle La Vie
diffusé pendant 18 ans sur France 3
comment aurions-nous agi à sa place
si c'était la seule chance pour sauver
l'un des membres de notre famille depuis
2019 Marouane béréni réside à fuir de la
Roche de Solutré
dans sa maison de village il reçoit
encore du courrier mais personne ne l'a
vu depuis l'accident
je suis au courant de rien on est dans
le questionnement qu'est-ce qui se passe
quoi mais bon après
y passait
c'est tout quoi bon c'est pas c'est un
vrai mystère
un mystère qui s'épaissit avec
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour la
disparition inquiétante de l'acteur
rapidement les médias et la presse
people s'emparent de l'affaire c'est une
affaire qui pose beaucoup de questions
la disparition de Marouane Bérénice est
l'un des visages phares de Plus Belle La
Vie ses proches sont sans nouvelles de
lui moi je comprends pas comment un mec
comme ça il peut disparaître sur
facebook la victime en personne lance un
appel à l'acteur s'il te plaît j'ai
besoin de réponse rends-toi à la police
pour qu'il puisse t'entendre et si c'est
pas toi que la police puisse s'orienter
vers une autre direction
les hypothèses abondent
mais les certitudes sont rares les
éléments qu'on a c'est que l'été vers 23
heures au fameux club 400 il dit restait
10 minutes il consomme et il repart une
heure après effectivement
il procède un achat un débit de boissons
et d'alimentation dans le Maconnais
après j'ai pas d'autres éléments
d'information sur
sa fuite éventuelle pas d'indice non
plus dans l'entourage de Marwan béréni
ce matin dans le quotidien Libération
ses parents lui adressent une lettre et
l'implore de revenir Marwan notre fils
affronte tes peurs tu as le droit de
pleurer mais reprends ton chemin crois
en toi reviens on a besoin de toi la
production de la série elle n'a aucun
commentaire à faire les acteurs de Plus
belle la vie n'en savent pas davantage
tout le monde fabule personne sait vous
vous êtes appelés entre
quand vous avez appris la nouvelle
suppose entre ex Plus Belle La Vie vous
en avez parlé ensemble de ça non on a
l'impression que c'est un bout
totalement
[Musique]
rien ne filtre non plus du côté des
enquêteurs me connais
que vous faire la même éternelle réponse
on est tenu au secret de l'enquête
ça tourne en rond la prescription
aucun nouveau commentaire sur cette
affaire
le parquet de Mâcon lui rappelle qu'il
n'y a pour l'instant aucune poursuite
engagée contre l'acteur dans l'accident
de voiture l'enquête pour violence
volontaire avec délit de fuite est
ouverte contre X
reste à savoir ce qu'est devenu Marouane
béréni va-t-il refaire surface
certains le croient mort d'autres
l'imaginent cachés ou en cavale pour
l'heure la justice n'écarte aucune
hypothèse